One of the most common questions I am told is, Felix
How do you remain so humble?
And I gotta say
Being the most successful Youtuber of all time
Having the most views of all time
Being this attractive (sure pewds), being this charismatic
being this all-around wonderful being that everyone just loves,
it's not easy to remain this humble BUT WHAT I DO is I look at other humble people
And I appreciate their humbleness
And that inspires me to become even more humble.
I'm actually not just humble. I'm way more humble than I think you could even understand.
So let's explore some other humble people that we can find inspiration from, together.
(👏subreddit 👏review)
Calming music with beautiful intro title??)
The agony of being too beautiful to stay faithful.
ouhh (in pain)
Uh(in pain) .
This one hits close to home. I... I am extremely attractive.
(laughs)
And It's just a pain.
It's not just a pain, it is an
Agony.
One woman's !!VERY!! brave confession
Incredible
Absolutely, this this I feel this one. Alright, let's click on the next video. Oh!
Oops..
How is- what is this doing here?
Oh that times magazine hundred most influential people Felix Kjellberg article written by none other than Trey Parker himself
I can't believe THIS...
just popped up there.
Don't wanna brag but my neckbeard is looking
Ok today
huuuh...
This is so typical of so many youtubers
Their ego has just blown out of proportion that they don't realize when they're not being humble
Absolutely, disgusting behavior from jacksFilms. And I expect nothing less from him to be honest. I get it!
I'm not a celebrity
I just have over two billion views online and get approached by people
every time I go out in public. Yeah, that's right. Stop calling me a celebrity
I can't barely leave the door without the swarm of paparazzi and fans meeting me left and right
Please step aside
I am just a mere
human trying to walk along you
Stop calling me a celebrity because I am NOT. Never changed on easy on.
The new pope is a humble man
Very much like me which is- which probably explains why I like him so much.
I understand this one humble beings get attracted to other humble character
That's this simple science fact, if you're not humble, then you probably can't understand this
- You're not known to be a humble man, but I wonder...
- I think I am actually humble
I think I'm much more humble than you would understand
🤣🤣🤣
I love this clip. He's so awesome
That's an example of a humble man. No one likes someone that brags constantly
Son: Oooh! NO WAY. NO WAY!
MOM
MOM!
Mom: Yeah?
Son: I'm a 443 subscribers!
Mom: WHO GIVES A SHIT?
Son: Ow
🤣🤣🤣
Ow
ooOwWWw
🤣🤣🤣🤣🤣🤣
See no one likes you ki- little kid. No one cares about how many subscribers you have
Stop bragging about your 450 subscribers. Did I mention that I have 62 million, by the way?
Oh, what is this?
The most handsome faces of 2017. Oh, I forgot this tab open. Oh, sorry guys, I was
Doing some research on humble people and this
showed up.
Not my intention.
I'm on a walk and cis guys keep checking me out.
UUUUUGH
All these boys just keep looking at me AAAHHH
Just don't you just hate when that happens, especially cis guys?
Absolute worst
Is it just me or does this paid off
2016 Ranger Rover make my new haircut look good?
A very nice combination of being humble about your haircut and your new vehicle at once. Very inspiring self
Oh, it keeps going. I've been doing this thing lately where I tip people
obscenely and give money to all the homeless people I see.
Literal saint here guys. What a humble character.
Love is when your seven-year-old knocks your
Woman of the Year Award off the shelf.
Did I mention that I was Woman of the Year...
Award, by the way?
Smashes it and you scoop him up and tell him it's fine because the work you did to get that award
is still out there in the world, and I don't need a big bronze eagle with my name on it
People already know
Especially thanks to tweets like this one
When I have a drawer
full of letters from readers whose lives have changed instead
he's more distraught than I am, poor sausage
I'm so glad they gave woman of the year to such a humble character
That doesn't like to brag... or at least humble brag.
A homeless woman asked me to buy her water
So I did. Two of the best brands
WOW
🤣🤣🤣
Literal saint! The best brands of water for a homeless person
Don't you think you that's a little too far? Don't you think that's spending money a bit too carelessly?
When I exited !WHOLE FOODS!
DiD I mENtiOnEd I sHOp fOod At Whole Foods?
I asked her to choose which bottle
Which- which bottle of water do you wha-ha-ha🤣
I did this action to remind MYSELF
That no matter what situation we are in we always have a choice
👏 👏 👏 Humbleness is a beautiful thing 👏 👏 👏
Incredible
👏 👏 👏
Now that's was this is all about.
The second thing I wanted to address in this video is the comments of me being a rich kid
I'm gonna go ahead and address you guys right now. That is not the case !SHUTUP!
That is not the case with this channel
You know, you guys might be on the wrong channel if you think then that I'm a rich kid of some sort
I'm just trying to address that guys. I just had worked very hard for what I've got on my channel and I take that
with pride and joy, and the last thing is
*curb your richkid*
Extremely humble characters. I just love how YouTube especially just breeds humble character
It's- it's a community just filled with people that don't wanna show off too much
It's not like it just rewards the whole channel by putting money in the title. Which creates a- eeh-
wonderful ecosystem of just humble characters such as me
I am so happy I gave up a scholarship to get my masters to become a youtuber
ha hah ah🤣🤣🤣
Is this me?
🤣🤣🤣
Yeah, I don't know if you guys knew this but I used to study Industrial Academy and Management
It was required
It would have given me a high-paid job and I didn't- I'm so glad I decided to go with what I love.
I never felt more ALIIIIVE
I'M SO HAMBLEEEEE!!!!
It's not every day that you have a dragonfly land on your finger when you're washing your car
You must know I donate a lot of money to these environmental groups
By the way, did I tell you ARJYGUYFJHINRDC?
A classic example of how to be humble. This completely unrelated thing happened
So this gives me a chance to be humble about what I am so great. I see a reoccurring pattern here
🤣🤣
Sure, they catcall me
Sure, they tell me I'm pretty. Sure my outfits are great
Sure, they tell me that my art can save the world
But does any of it mean anything?
Do they see the struggles and victories of an artist, a thinker, behind closed doors?
IS ANYONE SERIOUS anymore?
I think the same thing all the time. Yes, I have an extremely attractive
persona and face
But is anyone really serious? I have also extremely amount of intellects
collected in here. Does anyone even see that?
*applause*
👏 👏 👏 👏 👏 👏
Number one rule of being humble is that giving to the homeless. Only counts if you're filming it. Otherwise
Who's gonna know about it?
Even with 140 IQ
Did I mention that my IQ is 140?
I still can't install a printer
Even with 105 m...
thousand IQ
I'm still just a dummy like you guys
Even though I am incredibly smart. I am still just a dummy dumb
AVG protected you from several threats recently
AVG - the most HUMBLE!
🤣
Antivirus software of all time-
he heh he
🤣🤣🤣
*just regular humble jake paul's song*
This is the national anthem for humble characters. Such as myself and JP
My favorite part of the event
Hey, you have an interview in 10 minutes
Me: Sorry, I'll be signing stuff and taking photos until I have met everyone
*the same JP's song again*
we always have a choise
*thankfully*
*bye guys*
*brofist*